>> PRESIDENT TRUMP THREATENING
TO SEAL THE SOUTHERN BORDERS
AFTER TALKS STALLED.
AND SKIPPING HIS NEW YEAR'S EVE
PARTY IN MAR-A-LAGO DUE TO THE
SHUTDOWN.
NANCY PELOSI IS NOT IN D.C.
SHE IS ON VACATION.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
SARAH SANDERS GOING AFTER THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADER EARLIER.
>> RIGHT NOW WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
FROM HER, SHE IS UNWILLING TO DO
ANYTHING UNTIL SHE GETS HER
SPEAKERSHIP.
SHE IS MORE WILLING TO PROTECT
THAT THAN TO PROTECT OUR BORDERS
AND AMERICAN LIVES.
>> AND REPUBLICANS CALLING
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER A
HYPOCRITE FOR COMMENTS HE MADE
ABOUT BORDER SECURITY IN 2009.
>> ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS WRONG.
UNTIL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
CONVINCED WE WILL TOP ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION WE WILL MAKE NO
PROGRESS ON DEALING WITH THE
MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WHO ARE HERE NOW AND ON
RATIONALIZING OUR SYSTEM OF
LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
WE MUST DO AS MUCH AS WE CAN TO
GAIN CONTROL OF OUR BORDERS AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> LAWRENCE, I HAVE BEEN
THINKING FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS.
IS THERE A POSSIBLE DEAL TO BE
MADE HERE?
THE PRESIDENT GETS $2 MILLION
FOR THE WALL?
>> MILLION.
>> $2 BILLION, I'M SORRY.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT'S FRIDAY, GUYS.
IN EXCHANGE FOR SOMETHING LIKE
DACA?
IT'S CLEAR ONCE THE DEMOCRATS
TAKE OVER ON JANUARY 3rd, THEY
CAN PASS A CLEAN FUNDING BILL
WITH NO MONEY FOR THE WALL WHICH
COULD PASS THE SENATE.
COULD THAT DEAL WORK?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK A DEAL IS
POSSIBLE.
THEY DON'T AGREE WITH THE
SYMBOLIC MEASURE.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE -- THE WHOLE
THEORY OF THE WALL AND THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL IS GOING DOWN THE
ESCALATORS, ALL OF THAT IMAGE TO
THEIR VOTERS, THEY CAN'T DO.
THAT THEY WILL NEVER GIVE HIM
THE WALL!
BECAUSE OF THE SYMBOLIC MEASURE.
BUT I THINK THIS HIGHLIGHTS
SOMETHING.
LOOKING AT CHUCK SCHUMER, WHAT
CHANGED WITH HIM AND WITH BARACK
OBAMA?
SOMETHING HAD TO CHANGE.
I STARTED THE LAST SEGMENT
SAYING I FEEL LIKE THE ENTIRE
DEBATE IS DISINAGAINUOUS.
THEY KNOW YOU CAN'T HAVE AN OPEN
BORDER.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
I LIKE THAT CHUCK SCHUMER IS
BEING CONFRONTED WITH HIS OWN
WORDS HERE.
AS WE MAKE RESOLUTIONS FOR THE
COMING YEAR, YOU HAVE TO LOOK
BACK ON THE RESOLUTIONS YOU MADE
LAST YEAR.
>> UH-OH.
>> DID YOU FAIL?
AND THE YEAR BEFORE.
THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
DO.
THEY TALK A BIG GAME.
FOR A LOT OF THEIR VOTERS THIS
IS A NIMBY ISSUE, NOT IN MY
BACKYARD.
HE ACT SO SELF-RIGHTEOUS AND
THINKS HE IS SO MUCH BETTER THAN
THE PRESIDENT ARGUING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
I MAY AGREE WITH CHUCK SCHUMER
ON CERTAIN POINTS.
WHAT HE SAID A FEW YEARS AGO.
PEOPLE WHO COME INTO THE UNITED
STATES WITHOUT OUR PERMISSION
ARE ILLEGAL ALIENS AND THEY
SHOULD NOT BE TREATED THE CAME
AS PEOPLE WHO ENTERED LEGALLY.
>> HE PROBABLY STILL BELIEVES A
VERSION OF THAT.
ONE THING DEMOCRATS PUSH BACK
ON, WE FEEL LIKE THE PRESIDENT
IS JUST SAYING THE WALL WILL FIX
IT.
THE WALL IS THE END-ALL AND BE
ALL AND MEXICO IS GOING TO PAY
FOR IT.
NOW TAXPAYERS HAVE TO.
>> THAT'S A FAIR POINT.
I THINK IT WOULD DO HIM JUSTICE
TO TALK ABOUT THE OTHER ISSUES
AS WELL.
YOU TALKED ABOUT WHAT CHANGED.
ONE THING THAT CHANGED WAS
TRUMP.
TRUMP MADE THIS A PROMINENT
ISSUE.
REPUBLICANS DON'T PUT THIS AS A
LEAD ISSUE.
HE WAS OUT ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
TALKING ABOUT IMMIGRATION FIRST
AND TALKING ABOUT HOW MEXICO
WILL PAY FOR THE WALL WHICH I
THOUGHT WAS A MISTAKE.
HE PUT IT FRONT AND CENTER.
EVERYBODY THAT LOATHED HIM HAD
TO HATE THAT POLICY.
CHUCK SCHUMER SOUNDS LIKE DONALD
TRUMP IN THAT CLIP.
HE IS ECHOING THE SAME TALKING
POINT.
BECAUSE THIS IS TRUMP'S ISSUE
AND THE WALL IS A PRIORITY FOR
TRUMP, WHEN THEY OPPOSE TRUMP,
THEY HAVE TO OPPOSE THAT
MEASURE.
I WONDER HOW MUCH IS OPPOSITION
TO TRUMP OR OPPOSITION TO THE
ACTUAL POLICY.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS TALKED
ABOUT IMMIGRATION IN TERMS OF
FILLING SOME OF THE LABOR
SHORTAGES.
HE TALKED NEEDING WORKERS.
YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO HEAR
PRESS COVER THE KIND STATEMENTS
HE MADE.
THE PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT THE
WALL AS A FORCE FIELD.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> IT'S NOT A FORCE FIELD.
IT WON'T STOP EVERY TYPE OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND IT WON'T
STOP DRUGS BECAUSE THEY COME IN
THROUGH THE MAIN PORTS OF ENTRY.
THAT'S NOT THE BEST WAY TO
COMBAT THE DRUG PROBLEM IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> YES.
>> THIS IS WHY THE ARGUMENT
DOESN'T GO ANYWHERE.
THERE IS A WEIRD FALLACY THAT IF
SOMEBODY SAYS THE WALL WON'T
PREVENT X THAT NEGATES THE
PREMISE OF THE WALL.
THE WALL WON'T PREVENT
OVER-STAYED VISAS BUT A FENCE
WON'T PREVENT A FALLING ROCK.
YOU CAN SAY IF YOU WANT
SOMETHING, HERE'S WHAT YOU DO,
YOU PUT UP A FENCE.
AND HERE'S WHAT YOU DO FOR THE
OVER-STAYED VISA.
THAT ARGUMENT IS GONE.
YOU CAN USE THE FENCE FOR THIS.
WE SHOULD MOVE ON.
WE CAN'T WHEN IT'S PERSONAL.
THIS IS NOW PERSONAL.
THERE IS NO REASON TO REJECT A
COMP NICE.
DONALD TRUMP IS WILLING TO MAKE
A DEAL BECAUSE HE LIKES MAKING
DEALS.
LET'S FACE IT, HE'S MOVING TO
THE MIDDLE.
ANY TIME YOU EMBRACE DACA.
HE WILL MAKE A LOT OF PEOPLE
MAD.
HE IS WILLING TO DO ANYTHING FOR
THAT WALL.
IT'S IDIOTIC THAT THE
DEMOCRATS -- HE KNOWS YOU CAN
GET PIECE BY PIECE.
>> THAT'S THE QUESTION.
WILL HE BUDGE?
>> YES.
>> FOR WHAT?
>> THE POINT IS IT'S NOT HIM
NOW.
IT'S ABOUT CHUCK AND NANCY.
THIS IS LIKE A DIVORCE THAT
STAYS TOGETHER BECAUSE OF THE
KIDS.
WHAT YOU NEED RIGHT NOW IS A
MEDIATOR.
TO COME IN AND THERE AND HAS TO
BE AN ENGINEER WHO TELLS YOU
EXACTLY WHAT IS NEEDED FOR THIS
SPECIFIC PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
GOD KNOWS THESE POLITICIANS
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
THEY SIT THERE AND FALL BACK
INTO THEIR SAME ARGUMENTS.
THE WALL WON'T FIX X.
WE WILL DEAL WITH THAT.
HERE'S WHAT THE WALL IS GOOD
FOR.
THEY HAVE WALLS AROUND THEIR
COMPOUND AND THEIR SWIMMING
POOLS AND WHEREVER SHE IS
STAYING IN HAWAII HAS A WALL.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ABOUT DACA AND
CONSERVATIVES.
IF DACA MEANS AMNESTY.
>> RIGHT.
>> IF THE DEMS WERE PUSHING THIS
AGENDA IT WOULD BE HAILED AS A
HUMANITARIAN EFFORT.
IT WOULD CREATE MORE JOBS.
IT WOULD CREATE A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP.
BUT TRUMP IS DOING IT.
ANY TIME TRUMP DOES ANYTHING,
THE MEDIA HAS TO HATE IT.
>> WE WILL SEE IF HE VETO A BILL